Nature is full of organisms that iridesce
in wild displays of structural color
and some can even control it themselves.
While dyes and pigments produce colour
by selectively absorbing light, structural colors
are produced when light interacts with the
microscopic structure of a material.
Inspired by an organism that uses structural color,
the chameleon, researchers have created a biohybrid--
a color-changing gel embedded with living heart cells
that can display and control structural color on its own.
Their method involves placing heart muscle cells,
cardiomyocytes, onto biocompatible
gels with structural color properties.
The gels were made by arranging silica nanoparticles
on a glass slide and covering them with a
specialized gelatin.
This gel was then peeled off,
leaving imprints of tiny pores from the nanoparticles.
Some wavelengths of light disappeared
down into the pores, while others were reflected,
creating vivid colors.
When the heart cells swell and contract,
the gel does the same,
resulting in a shift in its structural color,
in synchrony with the pulsing of the cells.
By placing cells into tiny patterned grooves in the gel,
the team was able to create a material
that mimics a tiny butterfly flapping its wings.
As the cells expand and contract, the wings move,
displaying a changing structural color.
The team also showed that the biohybrid gels
could be combined with other materials to
mimic the functions of the heart
as a virtual “heart on a chip.”
Such a device could be used for biomedical testing
instead of using human or animal organs.
They tested the heart-on-chip by adding
various concentrations of a drug
which is known to change the heart rate.
Different concentrations of the drug
made the heart cells beat at different frequencies
and produce shifts in the structural colour of the gel.
This platform could make it easier to monitor
the effects of drugs in testing using only the naked eye.